yeah
look at him he's heading for that small
Moon
that's metal Moon New Hope the first one
made very bad feeling about it it's
really not a good movie it's really not
that good
my sons are major into Star Wars now I
don't know how it happened I tried to
Shield them from the fate of becoming a
Star Wars fan but against my wishes they
become obsessed with Star Wars it's like
something it's like almost something
evolutionary something clicked in their
minds and all of a sudden they're
running around the house with
lightsabers
side note to the side note on Friday my
my son says to me he says Daddy I want
to be a I want to be a Jedi when I grow
up
and I said oh you know me too I might
not be a big Star Wars fan but I I'd
love to be a Jedi and he said but you're
already grown up and you're not a Jedi
and I said yeah
yeah that's true
daddy you failed
yes I did
in so many ways son in so many ways kids
always know how to lift your spirits
like that but anyway um so I watched the
movie and uh
I'm you know I'm at the age of 33 now
and I'm I'm just now getting acquainted
with Star Wars universe so I have only
two questions I wanted to throw out
there always two there are
no more no less first of all and this
was bugging me the whole time I'm
watching the movie
are people drawn to the dark side
because they want to wear the cool
helmets and masks I've noticed a real
deficiency with the good guys when it
comes to cool helmets and masks why is
it that only the bad guys wear them and
they wear them when they don't need to
you've got like Stormtroopers walking
around the ship you know on friendly
territory and there's apparently the
ship's oxygenated so they could take the
helmet up but they're you know they're
in the break room having some coffee and
they got the helmet still on so
um but and I get it because it looks
cool it's a cool look
and I'm my thing is the good guys they
could probably I mean
kylo uh you know kylo Ren right the
whole reason he went to the dark side is
honestly just that he wanted to wear a
cool helmet and he wanted to look like
Darth Vader that's the whole reason this
only reason he became a bad guy I think
the good guys could really stop that
from happening and kind of stop the
bleeding as it were losing all these
Jedis to the dark side if if someone
just ran to Party City and grabbed some
costumes and then they could say to
somebody like kylo Ren no no look we got
costumes too you know you want your own
costume you want to design something
that's fine we've got people that can
make costumes kylo Ren is a punk and
then my second question and this this
really this this bugs me the most
and this honestly might be one of the
main reasons I never got into Star Wars
you're in a galaxy with extraordinarily
advanced technology we're talking so
Advanced that just your average commuter
ships can go the speed of light that's
the kind of Technology you have
on top of that you got robots that have
that can pass the Turing test they're
conscious C3PO appears to be conscious
right he has thoughts and feelings
really advanced technology and yet
you're using swords
the lightsaber is a glorified sword it's
a laser
An Elegant weapon
but a more civilized day all of this
technology and you're using a sword to
fight people
you're telling me you couldn't come up
with a weapon that would make that sword
irrelevant and if a guy comes at you
with a laser sword you could just shoot
him right and that'd be the end of it
now I know you're going to say oh well
they could block what you see in the
movie they block the lasers with their
sword yeah that's because the laser guns
the lasers that come out of the lasers
and the laser guns are super slow you
see all slow those lasers are they they
go at the speed of a Nerf bullet and
that's why they're so easy to block and
everyone gets on the stormtrooper's case
when they say the joke is that
Stormtroopers can't hit anybody and they
got the worst aim in the Galaxy but the
reason is that the lasers are going so
slow so they're easy to dodge so why not
make a gun with a laser that goes the
speed of an actual laser he's too
dangerous to be left alive and in lieu
of that just get a regular gun like a
sawed-off shotgun and you could kill
every Jedi in the Galaxy no problems
I have The High Ground you underestimate
my power
it just doesn't make any sense
and it bothers me you know a company's
looking out for you when they actually
upgrade your service and they don't
charge you for it pure talk just added
data to every new and existing plan
they're also including a mobile hotspot
with each new plan as well with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but you haven't made
the switch you need to take a look again
for just twenty dollars a month you'll
get unlimited talk text and now 50
percent more 5G data plus a mobile
hotspot I love pure talk not only do
they offer great services but they also
happen to be veteran owned and they only
hire the best United States based
customer service team available remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com Walsh you'll save
an additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that's
puretalk.com Welsh puretalk Wireless for
Americans by Americans the reviews for
this new Star Wars movie
have come out and right now last I
checked on Rotten Tomatoes I think it's
got like a 58 which is bad rotten
according to Rotten Tomatoes
and so it's just it's just being
abysmally rated I think it's going to
end up being perhaps the worst rated
reviewed uh Star Wars movie yet and even
even worse than Phantom Menace which was
a which was an abomination in so many
ways as most people know say something
about the prequels there's
only so much story to be told so this is
what the ninth Star Wars movie and it's
not even cat I'm not even counting all
the other peripheral things and the
offshoots and the you know other uh
spin-offs and the TV shows so there's
even more than that but just in the in
the primary film franchise we're now on
the right ninth movie right and if
they're each about two hours long on
average let's say talking about 18 hours
18 hours is that really 18 hours worth
of story to be told based on this I'm
telling you if you watch that first Star
Wars movie new hope it is really not a
good movie okay it honestly isn't it if
you go in if you go in cold it's really
not that good Matt straight up sucks the
acting is bad if Mark Hamill is not a
good actor but I was going into Toshi
station to pick up some power converters
the script is not good the dialogue is
clunky and and everything it's kind of
campy and kind of fun I guess but it's
not my point is it's really not a great
film and then you have to look at that
and ask yourself is there 18 hours worth
of material to be mined from that even a
really really great film
which with with with that is complex and
dense and with great characters and and
everything you're probably not going to
find 18 hours worth of material from it
but the first Star Wars movie isn't even
that great and it just goes on and on
and on
each new Star Wars movie it just repeats
it's over over it's the same story
repeated over and over and over and over
and over again how many times do we have
to see the same story while the Star
Wars universe
I don't think
has enough in it to justify 18 hours of
story the actual Universe does what I
mean is if you want to make a movie a
sci-fi movie about things happening in
space where it involves aliens and
spaceships and Adventures I say great do
that this is literally endless
possibilities for telling stories set in
space but all of our all the resources
in Hollywood everything is focused on
well if we're going to tell a space
story it has to be Star Wars it's like
just can we get away from the Star Wars
thing and if we if we have filmmakers
and and script writers and actors who uh
want to you know be in a do a movie
about space just let them do that we
just it doesn't need to be Star Wars can
we just put that aside fine we've done
Star Wars we get it but people are just
itching I gotta go I gotta go see it
again
yes
I've seen the same movie eight times
already
and now I gotta go I gotta go on opening
weekend to watch it again one more time
I gotta I'm just gonna I'm gonna hand my
money over to Disney give you some money
go see a Star Wars they have no respect
for me as a as a fan as a viewer because
they're just they're just they're just
shoving tripe into my mouth it's garbage
they're not even trying to make an
original story
it just reheated some leftovers and you
go and you give them their money and
they literally shovel it into your mouth
I mean who would do that
this is what we do with Hollywood I
don't understand
[Music]